myelin what is boundaries about I call
it a visual verbal sketchbook in that
it's half written half timid half images
it's images of all my work from the
first room from the first Memorial and
then basically from 89 to 99 it spans
ten years of work art architecture the
monuments and it's about the in-between
areas I sort of see the memorials as
being hybrid somewhere between art and
architecture but it's as much about you
know my east west back heritage art and
architecture the fact that I use science
a lot in my work since between science
and art it'sit's not in terms of when I
talk when I thought of the word titled
boundaries I'm not thinking just the
space on either side but the actual line
that divides and thinking of that line
as being a place that takes on
dimensionality it takes on a sense of
shape how much do you have to do with
the photography um I actually took I
would say maybe 30 40 % of the pictures
and then I am then I am selected
everything else what's this
this is a picture taken by a friend of
rocks and a stream and again this one is
the lead-in I I just I write a lot when
I make a work so this one is water out
of stone glass like that flows like
water the fluidity of Iraq stopping time
and it just sometimes I really sketch
verbally and that actually was just
thoughts I had about my work and then
the book designer started working with
me and started composing images and the
first for weed and photographs of the
book in the end are all from nature and
I and I talk about how so much of my
work is inspired by the natural
landscape and so I deliberately wanted
to end and begin the book with works
that are not that are from nature where
is this picture from this is um an image
stock photograph taken from I think
I can't remember which desert but it's
all about I you know I see myself as
existing not on either side but on the
line that divides just like the image
that starts the book is at the edge of
the ocean which is again where does the
line of water and and where does
landscape begin so the initial side of
the book is I feel I exist on the
boundaries and then it's just I actually
again had a friend go out and shoot that
image for me you dedicate the book to
your family and your late father yes why
why your father because my father and my
mother played a very strong influence on
my um my aesthetic and my father was a
ceramicist and a potter and actually
there's an essay in the book called
shaping the earth which is about which
is in a way how I think when you're a
child you um you're not a you're not
aware of things that are right next to
you that are so obvious to you and the
beginning of the book is my hands
holding a rock and in this essay shaping
the earth I talk about how you know
everything from the pots we ate from to
the furniture we we grew up with my
father made and it never occurred to me
until after my father died and I was
looking down at him that his hands were
extremely delicate and graceful apotres
hands you know I thought of my father is
a much stronger forceful type person and
in the end I say it I say he I didn't
realize this he gave me his hands and
with that came though I couldn't pull a
pot to save my life but just his ability
to work with clay I translated into
other mediums because a lot of the
sculptural materials I use are very
plastic sculptural materials clay wax
led beeswax almost fluid not quite hard
glass is technically a supercooled
liquid it's not a solid so everything
slightly plastic fluid mediums
and um and I entitled that as a shaping
the earth because so much of my um even
my building started in plasticine it's
it's a model material that has oil as
opposed to water so it never dries and I
basically carve carve artworks out of
the earth and a lot of what I do where
was your father located that he was a
ceramicist um he trained at university
of washington where my parents met and
Ohio University in Athens Ohio where I
grew up and he was first ceramics
professor professor there and then
director of Fine Arts and then Dean of
Fine Arts so I actually grew up as a
child on an arts campus I was casting
bronzes by the time I was in high school
I was sort of escaping from high school
to go play in the art department one of
the first things in your book is a page
of written workers actually printing
what is this this is um the essay I
wrote that I submitted along with the
drawings for the competition entry
number 1026 which i think is also in the
book and I basically designed the
memorial as part of a school project and
a memorial the Vietnam Veterans Memorial
and then when I decided to enter the
actual competition
I knew drawings wouldn't quite describe
it so I actually took many more months
to write that description which really
was about an experience passage of what
that piece is about and how you would
walk through it to experience it and I'm
pretty convinced it's that essay with
these very ethereal pastel images I
think one of the jurors made it made a
comment as he was walking past in the
selection process he must really know
what he's doing to dare to do something
so naive but then they kept coming back
to the design and I think it was this
again mix of something very very
pastoral these sketches very very very
young and then this witness
now what year was your design that was
1981 I designed it and entered it in
1982 how old are you an 81 I was 20 21
and where did you design it I was at
Yale as an undergraduate what year were
you I was a senior in fact as I was
graduating from college the day I
graduated I was driven down to
Washington to begin to work on the Royal
now this copy that you have in this book
you say you wrote back in 1983 and put
it away pretty much I mean I did do a
little editing when it finally came
around to it but yeah I basically a lot
of people at the time asked me if I
would talk about the controversy and I
didn't and I didn't want to and I think
that article was actually written for an
arts magazine and I couldn't I couldn't
get myself to submit it I don't know why
I think I realized after I saw the
documentary freedom montgome there was a
documentary that came out in 95 and it
covers the memorial and it covers some
of the controversy Freda was very
careful to never let me be aware of how
much taped footage she was using because
she knew that I'd probably never agree
to let her do this documentary because I
was putting it aside I was saying I
don't want to deal with this I was sort
of shine tuning out and it was actually
quite um emotional for me to see the
documentary I didn't see it I
deliberately respected her view was an
artist I waited till it was completely
done and then I saw it in a theater and
I I was bawling I was literally for two
days I was fairly upset because it
brought back a lot of tough times that I
happily had kind of put away before we
asked you more about that
where you live now New York what do you
do um I have a studio I am work downtown
and I basically spend my time between
art and architectural projects pretty
much all over the country I don't take
on too many architectural projects
because
because I want to spend as much time on
the artworks I don't want to have a firm
I don't want of a large place I have
maybe two to three assistants at any
given time some trained in art some in
architecture because again I can very
very rarely find someone who mixes the
two and can balance and and then like
right now I'm finishing up three or four
or five buildings and I'll go back into
my studio so I again split my time sort
of back and forth I juggle how much
education to you how much education I
guess I went for years undergrad in
architecture and Yale took a year off to
build the memorial tried to go back to
architecture school at Harvard found
myself taking one too many shuttles down
to Washington to testify because that's
when the controversy was fully blown
went back to Yale in 83 and finished up
my master's degree there do you have a
family I have a family I have a husband
Daniel Wolff is an art dealer and two
children two young children I've got two
girls a three-year-old and sixteen month
old so I basically am going to be
spending as much time worth playing with
them is working in my studio so I'm
gonna disappear for a while go back to
what you said earlier you said the
controversy yeah what was the
controversy you know I mean in a weird
way I don't I briefly talked about in
the book what was the controversy that
controversy was that people didn't like
the design that was selected after it
was selected and I think people felt
that on a lot of different reasons it
was not your traditional color it was
not your traditional shape it was not at
all vertical it listed all the names it
did so chronologically it was not usual
and I think it also I think was
controversial partially because of who
designed it was Asian
and I think that was misinterpreted the
wrong way
and so I think for a brief period of
time and I do want to say it
was unusual how short a time it took to
get this memorial built it was I think
very hot we debated I think there were
many criticisms that someone as young as
I was who could never have experienced
or understood that war how could she be
the one left to design something and I
think oddly enough because I was too
young to have been embroiled in the
politics I had made a choice I actually
unlike many of the designs that I've
worked on since then I consciously
decided not to read anything about the
politics surrounding that war I made a
call that the politics shouldn't get in
the way of this work that you were going
to have people his names are listed who
believed they should be there and those
who protested it who who went because
they were drafted I wanted both sides to
be able to rest and not overtly get
involved in forming an opinion and I
think this happens in many of those my
works and I think a lot of people say
well you're a political artist I would
go no not necessarily I am drawn or have
been drawn to work on issues war race
gender but I don't have an overt
political statement that I want to get
across if anything my approach to the
moment the Vietnam Memorial was to make
a piece that would be neutral and yet
would ask us to face these individual
lives lost on an individual basis now
that's new that's to experience
one-on-one and the veterans chose to
have the names listed though I designed
this for a class I found out halfway in
the design that they requested all the
names to be listed that inherently is a
political statement that we want to
recognize these individual lives lost in
it and I think a lot of artists and
designers when they saw that almost
looked at that requirement as a chore so
they'd find a form and then they were
trying to stuff
the names on it I basically allowed the
names to be the memorial that's it
because in a way I mean I went back to
the idea of what I mean a lot of
criticism was it was abstract you know
it's modernist it's cold it's inhuman
and I kept thinking well what's more
realistic to bring back someone's memory
than the person's name no one image
no one edifice is going to recollect and
react to you the way a person's name
well you mentioned about being Asian
where were you born
Athens Ohio and where were your parents
born my mother was born in Shanghai and
my father was born in Beijing and you
say in the book that you designed this
before you saw the land no I thought up
what ideas I had about how I wanted to
be honest about war how I wanted it to
make it very honest about the names and
about about acknowledging loss I thought
about what a memorial you know to the
Vietnam War should be in terms of
thoughts generally behind it then I put
all that thinking aside and I went to
see the site and it was on the site that
I just decided I'd cut open the earth
had you entered your to the contest no I
basically it was the fall of 1981
you know the springavator know the
spring of 80 not the the fall of 1980
we're in class we're studying aerial
architecture a group of us is a senior
at Yale you can choose your thesis that
six of us got together and decided we
wanted to study architecture and how it
relates to mortality in other words how
man deals with his own mortality in the
built form we found an advisor professor
Andy brewer who agreed to be our
professor and we started designing
projects you know one was a memorial to
World War three
I can't remember some of the other
assignments someone saw a poster of
Vietnam Veterans Memorial competition
and we thought what a great way to end
the course we'll have our own design
charrette and so I designed it but I had
started researching it when I was
researching world war the memorial to
World War three and so I started looking
into an idea of well what is a war a war
memorial what what has it been
historically what is it now and and then
I went to see the site it was around
Thanksgiving time I had actually gone to
see my parents and then on my way back I
rendezvous with a bunch of the students
in the class and we went to see the site
and it was a very cold day I took one
look at the site and I actually thought
it was a beautiful park and again I
didn't want to make a piece that would
overwhelm the site got some video that
was shot yesterday and this is you know
near the end of October and on the
screen there is the Capitol show you
kind of a perspective for someone who's
never been here this is what you saw
when you came yeah well I didn't see
that
no but you saw this piece of life I saw
this beautiful park and I think in the
end essay I say I still want the site to
remain a park a place where people could
come to it that nothing I think of them
where I didn't mean it I want people to
see where it was going nothing I did I
still wanted you to be able to walk on
to the site and again anything I've done
has been a merger with the landscape
it's not been about creating some large
powerful form that in a way supplants
the land so it's about working with I
mean there's a real there's sort of a
harmony going on and in a way you know I
basically had wonderful agreements
disagreements with the architects of
record Cooper lucky because they could
not understand why I wouldn't want to
make such a thin veneer surface this is
a monument make those walls two to three
feet thick and I kept boy no no I don't
see it as like a physical presence
inserted into the land I literally see
it as a geode I'm polishing the earth
and putting the names on that surface
you see they're healthy how it's very
very thin you said that the black
granite couldn't be bought from Canada
or Sweden yeah I mean we I mean this is
the funny thing um it was very odd all
of a sudden we were working with the
veterans about everything got
politicized down to we looked at Swedish
black granite we looked at Canadian
black granite we looked at South African
black granite we settled on Indian black
granite and I remember one of the
comments from the veterans was it would
be very hard to find a granite from
Canada or Sweden because again there
were draft dodgers who went there so
weak they didn't they wanted a neutral
neutral territory why I mean it what was
it again it was highly by that point it
had become fairly highly political and I
think there were questions about one of
the juries being a member of the
Communist Party things like that they
wanted the thing to remain as neutral as
possible because I think at that time it
had gone in under the Carter
Administration it was being built under
the Reagan administration and you had
basically an attempt at one point I
think of politicians that even though
this is a neutral statement we need to
pull it a size the design and there was
actually a real question as to at the
apex because I had not put in anything
there well they came up with a paragraph
in a paragraph that would have added
sort of a political meaning and I kept
going well we've got 1959 and it's yay
high and we've got 1975 and it's what's
put in three lines and again just keep
it very simple keep it so that you don't
add a political meaning you let people
come to this place and come away with
their own thoughts we've got some video
where one of the park rangers is you
know scratching the on the piece of
paper for somebody wants to see the name
did you think that would happen I didn't
think past one thought I knew people
would touch the names and I actually
knew people would cry I I don't know why
I knew that
other than that I really didn't think of
how it would be read as being such a
popular piece I think I mean I think
it's the only way I got through that
time I only could think of one person's
reaction to it always and that's the way
I always am it's a one-on-one experience
you wanted monological mm-hmm and they
aren't they are they are absolutely but
chronologically and in time but not
medical no absolutely I'm the chronology
to me and it begins and ends at the apex
it's like an open book 59 the beginning
of the war with the short prologue 75 at
the bottom on the left it's like an open
book at the beginning and at the end of
the war meet the war comes full circle
it's a close timeline but it's broken by
the earth by having the names be listed
chronologically any returning veteran
can find his or her time place on the
memorial and in so doing if you know one
colleague you'll find others in close
proximity and I I was trying to tap into
a sense of bringing them back to that
immediate memory there's something
called you know I talked about stopping
time where present past future it all
kind of comes to a point and by having
to relive that past it forces you to
face it and then you have to walk out
into into the present time tell the
story about how you found out you had
one oh it's a it's a strange one I was
in class actually and I entered the
competition as an exercise you know
students do it it's good practice I
believed in it but you know you don't
enter something like this at the age of
twenty twenty-one you forget about it I
get a call from my roommate and she
calls me out of class because you just
got a phone call from Washington they're
calling back in five minutes you've
never seen someone run fast or out of a
class my professor was sort of wondering
what's going on and they called up some
people that said well we're from the
Vietnam Veterans Memorial Fund
could we come ask you a few questions
about your design and I was convinced I
was number 100
not a big deal they just were asking me
a few questions like drainage or
something like that and they all flew up
and there were three of them and they
sat down in my dorm room and I think it
what they told me later is they were
freaking out because I wasn't just a
student I was an undergraduate and they
were going to an undergraduate dorm and
Saybrook college yeah and they're all
sort of hunched ins are the living room
and Colonel Shay was talking in this
very sort of unemotional way about well
this was the largest competition ever
held open to everyone and you want and
then he kept going he didn't miss a beat
and I'm like just listening and my
roommate catches it before I do but
again I mean I'm a funny person in that
it took me until it was built I did not
believe this would get built that I knew
it was formalistic away extremely
different and I'm also someone who never
like counts you know counts on anything
until it's real and so I basically
braced myself because having studied
competition processes as an architecture
student well it's very rare that
something gets built the way it was
conceived it just doesn't happen that
way what do you get for for building
design oh my god I got an award I got
man ok no they they gave me uh the the
competition award and there are 1,400
entries yeah when did you know that it
was gonna be tough um what was the first
time you said this isn't gonna be all
that very early on it was they had
shuttled me down they had flown me down
to Washington to meet with the whole
Vietnam veteran fund and I'm actually a
very shy person and I didn't know what
to do and they wanted the thing kept
very close so I called my parents but
they didn't want me going talking to
anyone so I was fairly isolated and it
was the very initial press conference
and they made a model they didn't talk
to me they just made the model and they
had pushed the design way to the back
and I said at one point you know that
model isn't accurate you really want to
split the difference between no no it's
just a press conference mom
don't don't worry about it and I'm going
it is such a simple piece everything
matters and I could just I instantly
read that there was going to be
interesting issues coming up as to how
something like this was going to get
realized and I actually I talked about
it in the book a little that I basically
went through a very internal very tough
struggle as to who the architect of
record would be who would work with me
to get the thing built and I think at
the time I think they took one look at
me and to be fair to them they thought
it she's a kid and she can't she
certainly you know and I did a lot of
publicity because it was sort of a
direct fun driven situation and they and
I was caught doing a lot of interviews
but basically all I was concerned about
was making sure that what I am what I
envisioned got built so I think from the
start we had sort of cross purposes they
sort of assumed oh you wouldn't want to
be interested and you're just a kid and
and it's so simple it's so simple which
and I'm like I am obsessive about
detailing down to the whatever anyway
the end result is the architect records
selected was who cesar pelli who was
then Dean of Yale had recommended I
think he was the absolute right choice
but there was a little bit of an
internal power struggle that left
grudges and I think those grudges left a
little bit of ill-will so that they
didn't know where I was coming from and
I didn't know where they were coming
from and it all was you know it all
smoothed over in the end but it left the
entire process a little difficult going
through more of our interview with Maya
Lin in a moment Ms Lin's work on the
Vietnam Veterans Memorial and other art
and architectural projects is only one
of nearly 80 stories taken from the past
15 years of booknotes TV interviews
found now in book notes on American
character people politics and conflict
in American history it's available in
bookstores and online now back to our
book notes
you with Maya Lin won a few names you
use in the book is Ross Perot right what
do you think of his involvement you know
Ross was part of a group that basically
felt that the veterans what they really
needed in fact I think he came over once
I was working in the architects office
and said aren't aren't aren't you sure
they just don't need a parade and I was
sitting there going no that's actually
not what they need something that makes
them real feel the catharsis you have to
face the situation in order to get over
it if you pretend it never happened if
you pretend it wasn't traumatic that's
not going to help you
so I basically saw Ross and company as a
group of very well-intentioned people we
just basically had a huge disagreement
as to what would help I want to ask you
about two statues yes know their
favorite topic the first one will show
is the statue of the soldiers mm-hmm do
you know when this was built 8283 and
why was it built I would say it was
built and it was a done deal
before anyone had seen or experienced
the memorial and that and a compromise
had to be agreed upon when Perot
and company started fighting the fund
and they were very Admiral to defend the
design we were fighting for
groundbreaking groundbreaking was not
allowed to go forward unless the idea of
a compromise more human more figurative
work would be built the Jews - no I did
not sculptor Frederick Hart was was
given the Commission now originally
those statues which are higher than ten
feet and the wall is only ten feet tall
their original intention was to place
the statues right at the apex so their
heads would be poking up above the
design I fought that very hard I I can
say that yes at the time they didn't
understand what the piece would be they
thought it was going to be this very
cold modernist IV leader
doing this intellectual thing the sad
thing is through the course of the
summer I actually was told by Park
Service officials that the then
Secretary of the Interior watt would
visit the site quite often and at one
point he he just apparently told a Park
Service employee you know it's too bad I
kind of like this pace but it was too
late they had already decided on the
addition so then it became a battle as
to where those statues would be placed
and I can only be happy that they were
moved outside so that you don't have a
confusion of two works working right on
top of each other and you basically have
I mean I say it I mean it's sort of like
the memorial that placement in a way
come memorializes the battle because you
had an idea a figurative is less
figurative is more responsive to humans
than then the abstraction of the names
the other statues are the nurses the
nurses my only comment on that is one
again I heard someone say well if the
three men weren't there we wouldn't want
the three women and it's a pity that
basically one is added to balance out
the other and both I find totally
unnecessary and when was this this one I
can't remember but it was later it was
later and it's it's a little bit farther
it's on the other end farther away so
that basically it's almost like the one
is to balance off the earlier one the
women they're to balance the men the man
I think had they only waited til this
was up they would have understood that
it is a memorial meant for the living as
well as the dead see their argument was
oh no that's for the dead we need
something for the living soldier when
they didn't really understand what the
impact would be how did this whole
experience change your life oh I went
right back into graduate school and got
to work very hard at work and I mean I
think the body of the work that's in the
book is 10 years 89 to 99 and it's a
body of work that spans monuments
artworks
and architecture and I think you know
the civil rights memorial was the work I
completed after the
Vietnam and in so doing Southern Poverty
Law Center asked me to if I would
consider making a memorial to civil
rights and I was of two minds one I was
very aware of how large the Vietnam
Memorial would be in people's minds and
if I did yet another Memorial would I
indeed be typecast but secondly I was
stunned that there hadn't been a
national civil rights memorial and as I
started reading about the history of the
civil rights movement I was shocked I
didn't even realize that in 1963 someone
was killed for using the wrong bathroom
that even though I was a child growing
up in these time periods
I hadn't been really taught it in school
and how frightening it is that we can
lose track of history we can forget so
quickly and so I began to think of this
piece as a is in a way a teaching tool
it's hard to see it I mean it's hard to
see what it really does here I'm going
to show it again in your book where is
it located it's located in Montgomery
Alabama at the Southern Poverty Law
Center's headquarters and it consists of
a water table which is a conical shaped
very asymmetrical table it's only 31
inches tall with water coming up out of
that's that whole center hole and
streaming over text and what the text is
it's a timeline and it begins in 1954
Brown versus Board of Education the text
goes around clockwise ending with Martin
Luther King's assassination in 68 it
intertwines people's deaths with
legislative events issues that happened
a riot happened a protest happened
someone was killed and again what I was
trying to say is that in history this
was a people's movement and sometimes
one person's actions led to better
legislation and sometimes legislation
went to someone's death through a riot
and it's like a causal effect and so
what I was trying to attempt was giving
people a brief glimpse of what that era
was about now what's this this is the
women's table which is
for Yale University I was asked it's a
sculpture it's a water table again where
water comes up and if you go to the next
page I don't know if you can see no
right the next pages and I guess it's
before that page before it yeah it's
hard to read so there's a spiral of
numbers coming out of the water font a
group of zeros then it goes to single
digits double digits ends with quadruple
digits what does it do
well I think then-president Venice
Schmidt had asked me to design a
sculpture dedicated to women at you and
I had no idea what that meant he was
thinking that it was 1988 when he called
me in 88 89 69 to 89 would mark the 20th
anniversary of co-education at Yale and
so I think he was thinking commemorate
that and I started researching all about
the history of women at Yale and I
started discovering you know the very
first class of women was in the 1890s it
was the School of Art and before that
women were allowed to sit in on classes
and they were called silent listeners
and I thought that's sort of a horrible
phrase were there but we're you know
we're seen but we're not heard so I
counted them so that spiral of numbers
counts the women at Yale enrolled both
undergrad and grad from when there were
none to the date in which I put the
piece in which was 1993 and so the
enrollment stops there and it's an
open-ended timeline
unlike the Vietnam which is closed the
Civil Rights which weaves a gap sort of
signifying past and future and then the
Yale table marks the beginning but of
course there is no end and it's a spiral
how long does it take you to do
something like the civil rights they all
take about two to three years from
beginning to end what do you do I sit
down and I research and read for maybe
three months six months sometimes nine
months for the artworks especially I
don't I don't have a deadline I
basically tell people these projects
take two to three years but I will not
work on a
you have to submit an idea by this time
because I don't want to force it so I go
through a very studied process and then
this you this is me climbing all over
what will become the civil rights
memorial I'm checking the seams on it
this is an Aquarian Vermont which put
the piece together for me so basically
it's two to three years to make a piece
just figuring out how the water would
flow the water doesn't drop at the lip
it turns the edge of that piece and
flows to the base so you don't get wet
when you walk up to it
so there are many technical aspects in
fact all of these works there's a clock
in there eclipsed time and actually a
clock I just dedicated it's Stanford
University the one at Stanford it's a
14-ton note 11 ton piece of stone that
tells the minutes the seconds the hours
and then what you don't realize is the
entire piece of stone is making a
rotation
it makes one rotation every year so it's
slowly moving so every time I seem to
when I've made the artworks I've sort of
reinvented and I've had to kind of
figure out how to get it built so
jumping to the end this is the Langston
Hughes library Haley farm Clinton
Tennessee and we'll pull back
Richard Hall's working our camera here
to show us this let's explain this this
is a library I was asked by Marian
Wright Edelman she invited me down to
Haley formants in Tennessee and she
wanted me to think about designing a
library and a chapel and I saw this barn
it was an existing barn it was not being
used it was completely derelict and and
I asked Marian what about putting the
library in this barn and so I cut open
the barn whatever is new is sort of on
the inside skin and I left the outside
very raw rustic except to maximize the
amount of daylight and then as you walk
up one of the cribs that raises the barn
up is your entry level stairs and
elevator upstairs the other one is a
bookstore and you go upstairs and the
entire inside is completely new with a
view out to the barn and
so it's all about mixing old and new
creating a raised a reading room up sort
of overlooking the pond and that pond is
also where I'm going to site the chapel
which I'm presently working on so the
idea was again I'm fixated in time old
and new so I've done something old and
something completely new
it was Langston here's Langston Hughes
was an afront african-american writer
and actually the sponsor of the chapel I
mean I'm the library when Riggio and his
wife Louise requested that the the
chapel be I mean the library be
dedicated to him
where's Clinton Tennessee Clinton
Tennessee is very near Knoxville and it
is the site of Alex Haley's old his
estates and do you have to politically
agree with whatever's going on in these
things they know you said you weren't
very you weren't trying to make
political statements but do you have to
agree with the politics or you can't do
it yes pretty much I mean they have to
be near and dear to me and I think I
take on I work with a lot of educational
institutions certain like right now I'm
working for a foundation called the
Greyston Foundation we're building a
bakery and Yonkers all their profits
they bake all of the brownies for Ben
and Jerry's and they all the profits go
to housing for the homeless and AIDS
Hospice
I get drawn in the architecture to
working with a lot of people that
actually probably wouldn't consider
bringing in design because I think they
can't afford it and like I finished for
NYU and asian-american Department we had
about oh we had about three to four
months start to finish the director
called me up and said you know I don't
know if you have the time but I actually
am challenged sometimes way that because
if I can make good design where normally
you wouldn't see designing it's sort of
a joy how often that when somebody you
introduce yourself to someone you say
I'm my lender they immediately know the
name nobody knows me nobody nobody knows
me I mean I have been recognized
so seldomly and I like that the works I
mean everybody knows the Vietnam War
but nobody would connect my face to it
or even my name and I I'm walking that
way because I really do believe the
works are out there and they're very
public but that allows me to remain very
very private which again it's that
dichotomy can you be very public you
know and in this world I'm lucky but I
don't think in art and architecture
you're recognizable normally outside of
your fields and it's it's it's nice I am
so you know not a celebrity and I never
will be and knock on wood now what
happens when they find out that you're
the person that designed the linka
having the Vietnam ro um people have
been incredibly kind and warm and in a
way they've shared with me very moving
very personal stories about that piece
and I think it's amazing I mean I don't
take it for granted that that first
piece out works so well for so many
people as an artist it's a double-edged
sword because you basically have to move
on and you move on emotionally as soon
as it's done so you know in a funny way
when a lot of people say you know what
do you do for an encore well frankly
like the image you're looking at there
is something the wave field which is the
sculpted waves of Earth that's
technically stumped me more in a way
that's way more is it this is in Ann
Arbor Michigan at the University of
Michigan for the Francoise Xavier bug
nude aerospace engineering building and
it is a 10,000 square foot artwork I
installed that is based on my studies of
fluid dynamics and flight I came across
a an image of a repetitive water wave
and knew the piece would be about that
that's probably one of my strongest
artworks and that led to a body of work
called topologies which went inside a
gallery and deal with landscape there's
a piece in there that is if you go the
other way I've seen it I'll have to find
it
what's this you
can i I'm sure it there thank you and
that is hard to see on very hard to soon
camera
what is it if you pan back if you if the
camera goes back a little bit you can
see the inter piece it's a 16 foot by 18
foot sculpture made out of cut particle
board I'm very interested in
stratigraphic stratigraphic layers of
the earth except this one I stacked or
vertically and it's just an undulating
wave field brought into a museum
environment so how could I take this
large-scale landscape aesthetic and
bring it inside the neutral grounds of a
museum so again I'm right I'm actually
right now working on a series of
mappings that will be almost I can't
always say but they'll they'll deal with
the topography of the ocean floor there
is a this memorial but work that you've
done in here for the Rockefeller rights
building Rockefeller Foundation in New
York yeah
it's called ten degrees north and it's
actually its centerpiece is a map of the
earth but when you first see it it looks
like much more of an abstracted
landscape and as you walk up to it and
especially from the second floor of
their Lobby you realize it's a map of
the world should I find it it's you're
very close to it it's right in sorry
it's hard to juggle when you write that
earlier and it's a it's a it's a it's a
series of benches tables sculptures
surrounding this entry area of which the
centerpiece is this cut in stone map of
the earth and water is percolating up
from the different trenches the Java
trance the Japan trance and the water is
the sea level water why is it called ten
degrees north you know when I started
researching about the Rockefeller
Foundation the well-being of mankind
throughout the world well when we start
helping out it's always through our
perspective and maps are inherently very
political and any rectangular projection
of the earth is distorted
and most of our views are a Makeda
projection where you've taken an equal
projection from the equator well there's
much more landmass in the northern
hemisphere towards the top of the North
Pole than in the south so are it
enlarges those areas so our image is
that North America and Asia are actually
much larger than they really are so I
asked a map maker to take the projection
from 5 degrees 10 degrees 15 degrees
trying to make it a little more
equivalent so it's all subtly about how
maps are very political and we actually
have to be careful from what perspective
we're looking at you also talked in your
book about this business about being an
Asian American and that right you were
born in Athens Ohio what year did your
parents come over to you guys
immigrated in the mid 40s they came out
separately my mother came out on a
scholarship to go to Smith College my
dad came out a little earlier and he
they met at University of Washington and
they brought us up my brother and I we
don't speak Chinese it was an age before
you were brought up bilingual they
wanted us to fit in and we did my you
know friends will say you're you're so
Ohio and you're so Midwestern I've never
met a more and then little by little in
my late 20s 30s as I started developing
my work I'm realizing I am really pulled
to as much of an Asian aesthetic this
non didactic you sort of bring allow
people to bring their thoughts it's more
subtle it's quieter it's all about
education and in a way about self
introspection and I in a way I rebelled
against a lot of sort of the standard
the Western European architectural great
works iin dedup studying in Japan for a
summer just so I could absorb some of
that cultural climate I went to Kyoto
and spent you know a good deal of that
summer there and you know I'm Chinese so
am i doing with an affinity towards
Japanese architecture I always felt a
little guilty and then I'm other-- takes
my brother and I back to China and we
get to visit my father's childhood home
and test bootcamp fook in Provence built
on a river it's got its near sue Joe I'm
terrible we sort of did a circuit we
went from Shia and Shanghai Suzhou then
into foucan and I'm working at this
house or what remains of it and it's
japanese-style house and I'm going to my
mother love it
what is this in it that's like Oh your
grandmother loved well your grandmother
loved Japanese architecture and they had
this house built in the style of a
Japanese house so there I am obviously
my dad grew up in this house he designed
much of the furniture and the way out of
our house in Athens and I you know you
grow up and you absorb what your
cultural surrounding is so again
something clicked and I'm going that's
perhaps this is where I get this a
strong affinity towards sort of the
Shinto shrines of Japan the Japanese
courtyard style houses it's also I mean
the amazing ability they have of framing
the landscape so no matter where you are
in the building you're really asking
someone to look out into a very specific
view of nature is your mom stolen yes
yes she's ash we're tired she was in
Athens Ohio and I'm actually gonna go
back and spend with my kids very long
Thanksgiving with her which I'm looking
forward to
did your father at Liv Lana to see all
this unfortunately not and I think
that's that's painful to me he didn't
even he didn't get to see the dedication
on the civil rights memorial did he get
to see their dedication the Vietnam era
yes he did and that was great and you
know I mean you just wish for certain
things and I think when you're you're
younger you think your parents are
always gonna be there for you so if my
father was considerably older than my
mother
so yeah the book is very special because
it's dedicated dad so much is about him
in a way when did you decide to do a
book after I saw the documentary in 595
yeah and then how did
go about doing this book well in a way
the writing was all there
because as I've made these works I've
written a lot about them sometimes I
started with a written sketch but to put
it all together I deliberately made a
book that its size is odd it's well is
it a coffee table book or is it a text
book so it's all about ambiguity and in
so doing I deliberately asked I chose a
publisher Simon & Schuster which is much
more known for in a way written books
and then I asked Michael rock of 2x4 to
be the book designer who's coming out of
sort of the high art architecture design
world and I watched as they just at
times did not know how to communicate
with one another because here's Simon &
Schuster and they're really used to
dealing with book designers who do the
Jacke jacket thank you very much and
here's Michael rock used to totally
controlling the show and and it was a
nice nice collaboration hustle at times
that that built up the work but in the
end the idea that the text and the
writing would be an equal balance to the
images was sort of the hybrid I was I
was trying to attempt here about adding
three years and at the very end you talk
about you have you don't like the
monument business I don't like the one
you're in business
well I retired after 89 didn't want to
get typecast I hope you can appreciate
the the position people were joking you
know put up a sign monuments by Maya I
mean I basically stepped away from it
except I've realized I have always been
since I was a child very concerned about
what man is doing to the environment I
look at us and you know scientists have
called what we're going through the
sixth-largest extinction of the history
of the planet by the way this is an
aerial satellite image of the earth and
I actually don't remember where this is
taken from but again I study mappings
aerial views glacial patterns again
taking inspiration like icon
active NASA this is an image I took of
an ice cave the detail of did you take
this person I took this picture where
this is in Seattle outside of Seattle
it's in a new Pilchuck where I did a
residency blowing glass and so what's
that last money we're gonna look like
well that's the interesting thing it's
going to if you think of a memorial
monument not existing in one place but
in many places all over the world each
site different each site unique all
taken together they will help give us an
idea of in a way the health of the
planet from global climate change to
land mass to extinction in endangered
species
I can imagine one of the sites I would
love to make out of a huge toxic waste
dump
so I'm trying I'll try to reclaim a site
maybe make one out of garbage some of
them will be in existing parks trying to
get them to be larger because I think if
we're really going to talk about
preserving to biodiversity we have to
talk about very large areas that we we
leave untouched I don't know I've
literally started it with the book I
start with a sketch I met with a group
of biodiversity scientists experts in
the field from plant to mammals and we
met last Tuesday and my guess is I'll
take a year to quietly ask a lot of
questions and then surface with the team
but if I could do something that would
help us prevent this mass extinction
that would be what I'd really love to do
I mean I sort of a I'm starting with
Yellowstone I'm actually doing an
artwork within Yellowstone they're our
first National Park and I'd love to try
to help make say Antarctica our first
international part because conceptually
what that would mean is that globe we
are working together to protect the land
was there ever a time and all that those
early 80s where you wish that this has
never happened yeah at times I mean yes
and no I think what I did was I just
forgot about it which I have a lovely
habit of doing and just focusing on what
interested in at the time I'm pretty in
that sense I think being an artist saved
me because I basically I just tunnel in
I have tunnel vision so I'm is intensely
interested in what I'm working on now
then what I did you know ten years ago
two years ago so in an odd way what I'm
interested in is the learning process I
go through and making each of these
works and then I kind of move on from it
where's your brother today he's in New
York he actually moved back to New York
i teaching in a small college and he's
doing his art work he's actually I mean
his poetry he's working on a second
volume of poetry and I'm he'll be in a
art show and I'm Chelsea and in the
spring so he's busy and he's teaching
creative writing which is what he really
wants to do so both of us sort of
followed in our parents footsteps and
have taken you know we're in the arts
what's his name Thanh Nguyen and you
have three names Maya
yang Lin England yang King yes silent
why why
ing J it's my Chinese name it's my
Chinese given name and it means precious
stone or Jimmy transmen in New York and
a dinner party and he does he's an art
dealer photography special there's been
19th century photographs does he work
with you at any in any of these projects
I mean he's very sweet and supportive
that he puts up with my incredible
nervousness as I'm making these things
he's actually got an incredibly good on
when you went back to China what was
your reaction overall do Y just come
from Japan and I found Japan very um
very formal and I think you know they
actually thought I was Japanese in Japan
and if you're english-speaking if you
don't speak Japanese they look at you
with a little bit of odd suspicion and
so you're not from the uf2
and I got to China and your overseas
Chinese they embrace you they welcomed
you you're coming home it's it was a
very welcoming feeling and
and then I got to meet my relatives a
lot of them for the very first time and
for someone who grew basically grew up
isolated with a family of three other
people it was pretty wonderful did what
was their reaction to your involvement
with the Vietnam War they understood
that I was basically an architect I
think I'm following in the footsteps of
my aunt my half-sister my father's side
we're essentially I mean I have a funny
legacy which I wasn't really that a
parent of win weigh-in and Liang Sicheng
were my aunt and uncle they were like
sort of the strong art historians of
China they catalogued most of the
architectural works historical works of
China they also help to bring modernism
they studied at University of
Pennsylvania went back to China in the
Communist revolution and they designed
Tiananmen Square so I was out there on
the plaza with one of the officials
saying well what do you think of
Tiananmen Square and I'm going it's very
large what was I going to say
obviously the Yanks are Chang after my
aunt had passed away later on realized
how modernism had how you know bringing
modernism to China heads help start you
know they tearing down a lot of the old
parts and he tried to prevent it and
tried to preserve and he fell out of
favor at that time because everything
was still about progress but they went
through the same thing we went through
which is why we lost on Penn
you know Penn Station in New York where
modernism was going to come in and wipe
the slate clean and then ten years later
we all turned around and said my god
what what have we taken down so you
kinda have to mix the older than you
this is the book we've been talking
about it's called boundaries by Maya Lin
this is the cover sells retail $40 thank
you very much for joining us you're
welcome thank you